تجدد الصراع وتجددت معه الدعوات الاقليميه
والدوليه للتوصل الى هدنه ومن ثم الى وقف
اطلاق نار تامه فقد اكدت السعوديه
والولايات المتحده في بيان مشترك على
الالتزام بمصلحه الشعب السوداني كما دعا
الطرفين نزاع لهدنه جديده خاصه ان وفدي
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع ما
زالا في مدينه جده حتى مع تعليق المفاوضات
وانتهاء مده الهدنه السابقه والتي استمرت
خمسه ايام الرياض وعواشنطن شددتا على طرفي
النزاع الالتزام باعلان جده الخاص بحمايه
المدنيين في السودان وتسهيل المساعدات
الانسانيه كما لفت البيان الى الانتباه
لضروره الالتزام باي هدنه جديده بهدف
التوصل الى وقف دائم لاعمل العنف
السؤال الان مشاهدينا لماذا لا تستمر
الهدنه في السودان محللون يجيبون بان
الطرفين نزاعي وافقان على اي هدنه بهدف
استغلال الوقت لاعداد ترتيب الصفوف
والتقاط الانفاس واعاده التموضع كما
انعدام اليات الرقبه الاقليميه والدوليه
على عمليه تنفيذ الهدنه يسمح للطرفين
باتهام الاخر بخرقها لكن الاهم انه من
الصعب اقناع اي من الجنرلين المتحاربين
برهان وحمتي بالتفاهم وتوصل لوقف النهائي
لاطلاق النار بينما كل طرف منهما يدعي
امتلاك الشرعيه ويرمي الطرف الاخر بتهم
مختلفه ويسعى كل منهما لان تكون له اليد
العليا في المفاوضات
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات